tu peux pas l'empêcher de rentrer juste
un service minimum est assuré
aujourd'hui dans cette résidence
collective située au monde au bleu au
carbet dès les premières heures de la
matinée les salariés affiliés à la cdmt
santé manifestent ainsi leur
mécontentement ils dénoncent de nombreux
dysfonctionnements au sein de cet ehpad
qui a vu le jour dans les années 2000
tarifs souvent que nos collègues à péage
des agents polyvalents qui sont au
minage se retrouve une personne pour 40
chambres à nettoyer le matin donc elles
doivent donner le petit déjeuner après
abandonné le petit déjeuner fait manger
les résidents il faut qu'elle fasse 40
chambres
il n'est pas normal qu'au jour
d'aujourd'hui qui l'y aide qui est pas
d'eau chaude
ici dans cet établissement pour
personnes âgées il n'y a pas d'eau
chaude des réunions et aux étangs tour à
la légère
l'établissement a déjà dix ans donc la
problématique de distribution d'eau dans
l'établissement est quelque chose dont
on a déjà échangé avec les salariés il y
a les études qui sont en cours et qui
sont bientôt terminés pour optimiser
l'eau chaude au niveau de
l'établissement
autre point très sensible dé lancer dans
la plate forme revendicative des
salariés grévistes
la surveillance nocturne des personnes
âgées
je suis seul pour 40 résidents le soir
il arrive que
il ya des gens qui déambulent et qui
partent aussi qu'ils fuguaient selon la
direction de cet ehpad privé qui
fonctionne sous la forme d'une sarl les
dotations de l'état et doit ctm doivent
être revues à la hausse
il ya peu de temps la ministre de la
santé a fait a fait des annonces pour
augmenter certaines dotations au niveau
des étals pour augmenter les effectifs
il faut comprendre que les effectifs que
nous avons dans nos ehpad quels qu'ils
soient privés associatifs ou autre ses
effectifs sont subordonnés ou dotations
que nous recevons de la rs et de la ctm
si ces dotations n'augmente pas nous ne
pourrons pas augmenter les effectifs en
début d'après midi les deux parties sont
entrés en négociation des débats très
tendu qui se poursuivent en ce moment